hey guys welcome back to brand-new river
back on apex legends again today we have
some interesting news to talk about
today a possible leak hinting at
vehicles coming to apex legends some new
legendaries and maybe even a couple new
legends coming to the game and what they
might look like as well as the new
patches just released today on February
13th those always like the VP do enjoy
subscriber for new I'll cover the news
of apex legends so everyone can be
up-to-date with what's happening in the
world of apex legends and with that
let's get started with today's video so
first up is a possible leak hinting at
vehicles coming to apex now I got this
from Dex theroad comm and it says
currently the only vehicle the players
can access in the game is the supply
ship that hovers above the map but can
only obtain loot from it it can actually
use it to travel around the map now a
data miner known as apex game info has
found evidence of a hover bike that has
been introduced through the game for the
developers but not yet made available to
the general player base now this doesn't
mean that it would be in the game or it
won't be in the game this could possibly
be a test on their side to see if it
would work with the flow of the game or
maybe it's a placeholder for something
for example one character in the game
that I still cover is a game called for
honor and one of the characters have
been foreigner his name is Morden but
when Ubisoft was developing the
character they didn't really know a name
for him so they put a placeholder name
which was sword Knight
now sword Knight and warden are not even
close so Hoverbike could also be a
placeholder for a certain name of
something coming in the future but the
only thing that the bunks this theory is
that the top of the picture shown I
believe it's a to-do list I know I don't
actually code so I don't know what any
of this means but I believe it's a to-do
list and it states that the bike should
be able to fit in the spawn location and
that there will only be a limited amount
of bikes throughout the map either way
let me know what you guys think in the
comments below personally I think the
movement is fine in this game and apex
does not need new vehicles but we'll see
how that goes I just limit like I said
let me know in the comments what you
guys think next up is the first patch of
apex and it has to do with the
Valentine's Day skins and a bunch of
other stuff Pathfinder got a banner
frame and the longbow got an epic rarity
skin now obviously these aren't in the
shop just yet they'll probably go live
in a couple hours from now cuz my item
shop hasn't updated I think it updates
in about 7 hours when I'm recording this
video so once the item shop does update
aspect a video later tonight showing you
what the VR what it is how much it cost
and if it should be worth it or not but
according to the post that these are
going to be available from February 13th
to February 19th and then they're gonna
be gone forever on top of this there
will also be some UI tweaks general bug
fixes things like the arc stars now
having a grenade icon and falling
through the map
is in this patch which is nice to see
that they're improving the game a little
bit more and then the juicy part of this
is the talking about the new legendaries
coming to the game and the new legend
characters so both of these were
courtesy of frozen fro on reddit so
credit to him he goes a lot more in
depth in his post on Reddit and as not
to claim the entire thing and get rid of
and yo and rid of all of his work I'm
going to briefly speak about it if you
want to see some more juicy details on
what he thinks and what it could be
check the links in the description and
leave an upvote for him I'd be greatly
appreciated so thank you frozen fro for
the for this and you deserve all the
credit my man so the new legends come
from the apex legends deep dive trailer
it shows over a wide variety of things
throughout this trailer but I want to
hit this part right now I'm going to
play on screen now those right there
don't look like our current legends
within the game now one of them looks
like a human and the other one has robot
legs we can easily pass this off as
Pathfinder but the one or the robot legs
according to frozen is an early concept
art of a pilot from titanfall as shown
on screen sadly though this character
was never actually brought into the game
that was only staying any concept art
phase of the game but who knows maybe
they'll bring it back in apex legends
and then the guy on the right Capasso
would be talcum a Korean with the Titan
within the titanfall universe who is in
pathfinders concept art I believe the
robot won more than the Korean guy cuz
in the trailer that legend is living
something very heavy on his back and
judging from the photo that frozen has
provided with us it doesn't really seem
like Tom has anything huge in his
picture but it could be behind him we
just can't see it so that's gonna be it
we'll take that with a little bit of
grain of salt there so let me know what
you guys think I'd be really excited for
this if Telkom is confirmed I'm
definitely gonna be playing him just
because I think he's gonna look crazy
cool and I wonder what their abilities
would be the more legends they add into
this game the more balancing they have
to do and making stuff and making
characters viable and making them not
garbage or overpowered so be really
curious to know so let me know in the
comments below what you guys think that
those characters would have is some
abilities passive tides going ultimate I
love to know and then lastly is the new
legendaries now this is also from frozen
but this is from the gameplay trailer
throughout the gameplay trailer show
they show banners of the current legend
in the game but having different gear
now some of this gear is similar to the
ones we already have in the game but
like the one in the Bangalore picture
this one's a different color it is very
similar to an outfit she has currently
in
like I stated but I believe the one in
game is a white color where this one has
a black color scheme and also very
similar to the bloodhound one his
samurai color scheme armors are red and
blue but not this white in a hint of
gold like it shows within the trailer so
in the near future we might see some
all-new different legendaries with
different types of armor or possibly old
Legendary's with different color schemes
so let me know what you guys think about
that as well there's about 6 voters
within this reddit post I'm gonna be
playing them on screen while I do the
outro but thinking as for watching this
video like to be if they do enjoy
subscribe for new like I said I cover
the news of apex legend I'm gonna try to
keep everyone up to date what's
happening within the world of apex you
never miss out on a single update you
can always be kept up to date so if you
want to know that deftly subscribe to
the channel I do appreciate that we're
gonna end the video off with the
question of the video and that question
is going to be how you guys enjoying
apex legends so far it's only been a
week and there's about 25 million people
already playing the game let me know
what you guys think of apex legend in
the comments below as well with any of
your thoughts throughout this entire
video just send me paragraphs I don't
care I read all the comments I'd love to
know all of your thoughts on this with
that guys like the view if you do enjoy
like I said my two most recent videos
will be on screen if you guys do want to
check that out with that guys hope
ever-greater day thanks for watching the
video and peace out
[Music]
you